let's do some practice problems dealing
with variable expressions so these first
problems say write the following in a
more condensed form by leaving out the
multiplication symbol or leaving out a
multiplication symbol so here we have 2
times 11 x
so if we have 11 x's and then we're
going to have 2 times those 11 x's we're
going to have 22 x's
so another way you could view this 2
times 11 x
2
times 11x you could view this as being
equal to 2 times 11 and all of that
times x and that's going to be equal to
22 x's you had 11 x's you're going to
have two times as many x's so you're
going to have 22 x's
let's see you have 1.35
times y now here we're just going to do
a straight simplifying how we write it
so 1.35 times y i'll do it in a
different color 1.35
times y that's a little dot there
in algebra we can just get rid of that
dot symbol if we have a variable
following a number we know that means
1.35 times that variable so that we can
rewrite as just being equal to 1.35
y we've condensed it by getting rid of
the multiplication sign
let's see here we have 3 times one
fourth well this is just straight up
multiplying a fraction so in problem
three this was problem one this is
problem two
problem three three times one fourth
that's the same thing as three over one
times one fourth
multiply the numerators you get three
multiply the denominators one times four
you get four
so number three i got three fourths and
then finally you have one-fourth times z
we could do the exact same thing we did
up here in problem number two that's the
same this was the same thing as 1.35 y
that's the same thing as 1.35 times y
so down here we could re rewrite this as
either being equal to 1 4
z
or we could view this as being equal to
1 over 4 times z over 1 which is the
same thing as z times 1 over 4 times 1
or the same thing as z
over
4. so all of these are equivalent
now what do they want us to do down here
evaluate the following expressions for a
is equal to 3
a is equal to three
b is equal to two
b is equal to two c is equal to five
c is equal to five and d is equal to
minus four or actually i should say
negative 4 is the correct terminology
negative 4.
so we just substitute every time we see
an a we're going to put a minus 3 there
or a negative 3 there every time we see
a b we'll put a positive 2 there every
time we see a c
we'll put a 5 there and every time we
see a d we'll put a minus 4 there and
i'll do a couple of these i won't do all
of them just for the sake of time
so let's say problem number five
problem number five they gave us two
times a
plus three times b
well this is the same thing as two times
instead of an a we know that a is going
to be equal to negative three
so two times minus three
plus
three times b what's b they're telling
us that b is equal to two so three times
two and what is this equal to two times
minus three two times minus three let me
do it in a different color
two times negative three is negative six
plus three times two three times two is
six that's positive six
so that is equal to zero notice the
order of operations we did the
multiplications we did the two
multiplications before we added the two
numbers multiplication and division
takes precedence over addition and
subtraction
let's do problem six
problem six i'll do that right here
so you have four times c
four times now what's c equal to they
tell c is equal to five so four times
five that's our c plus
d
d is minus or negative four
so we have four times five is twenty
plus negative four that's the same thing
as minus four so that is equal to
16
problem 6. now let's do one of the
harder ones down here this problem 10
looks
a little bit
more daunting
problem 10 right there
so we have a minus 4b in the numerator
if you can read it it's kind of small
a is minus 3. so we have minus 3 or
negative 3
minus 4
times b
times b b is two
so four times two remember just
this right here
is a
that right there is b how do i know
they're telling me up here
and then all of that over
all of that
is over
3c plus 2d
so 3
times what was c c is 5.
c is five
plus
two times d
what is d
d is negative four
negative four
so let's figure this out so we have to
do order of operations multiplication
comes first so before addition and
subtraction
so let's do
so this is going to be equal to minus 3
minus 4 times 2 minus 8
all of that over
3 times 5 is 15
plus 2 times negative 4 is
negative 8 or 15 plus negative 8 is 15
minus 8.
and now
let's the numerator becomes my negative
3 minus 8 which is negative
11.
and the denominator is 15
minus 8 which is 7.
so
problem 10 we simplified it to minus or
negative 11 over 7.
all right
there let's do a couple of these over
here okay we see some exponents
i'll pick one of the harder ones
one of the ones let's do
this one over here
problem 18
problem 18.
so 2x squared minus 3x squared plus 5x
minus 4. okay well this wasn't that hard
there all of them are dealing with x but
what we could do here so this let me
write this down two x squared minus
three x squared plus five x
minus four and they tell us that x is
equal to
negative one
one thing we could do is simplify this
before we even substitute for negative
one so what's two of something minus
three of something right this is two
x squareds minus three
x squareds so two of something minus
three of something that's going to be
minus one of that something so that
right there or negative one of that
something that would be negative one
x squared plus five x
minus 4
and they tell us x is equal to negative
1. so this is negative 1 times x squared
negative 1 squared
plus 5 times x which is negative 1
minus four
so what is this negative one squared is
just one
right that's just one so this whole
expression simplifies to negative one
plus five times negative one we do the
multiplication first of course so that's
minus five or negative five
minus four
so negative one
minus five is negative six
minus four is equal to
negative
10
and i'll do these last two just to do
get a sample of all the types of
problems in this
in this variable expression
section
the weekly cost c of manufacturing x
remote control so the cost to see x is
the remote controls
is given by this formula the cost is
equal to 2000
plus three times the number of remote
controls where cost is given in dollars
question a what is the cost of producing
1 000 remote controls
1 000 remote controls well the number of
remote controls is x
so for part a i could write over here
the cost is going to be equal to just
use this formula
2 000
plus 3 times the number of remote
controls x is the number of remote
controls so 3 times
one
thousand so it's going to be equal to
two thousand
plus three times a thousand is three
thousand
which is equal to five thousand
dollars so that's part a five thousand
dollars
now part b what is the cost of producing
two thousand remote controls
well the cost just use the same formula
is equal to two thousand
plus three times the number of remote
controls
so three times two thousand
three times two thousand so that's equal
to two thousand
plus three times two thousand is six
thousand
so that's equal to eight thousand
dollars
now we're at problem 22
the volume of a box without a lid is
given by the formula volume is equal to
4x
times 10 minus x squared where x is a
length in inches and v is the volume in
cubic inches
what is the volume when x is equal to 2
so part a
x is equal to 2 we just substitute 2
wherever we see an x here so the volume
is going to be equal to 4
times x which is 2
times
10
minus 2
squared
and so this is going to be equal to
4 times 2 is 8
times
10 minus 2 is 8
squared
and so that's 8
times so this is equal to 8 times 8
squared is 64. you can say this is going
to be 8 to the third power
and 64
times 8 4 times 8 is 32
6 times
eight
is
six times eight is forty-eight plus
three is fifty-one
so it's five hundred and twelve
five hundred and twelve
now what is the volume when x is equal
to 3
i'll do it here in pink b when x
is equal to 3
then the volume is equal to 4 times 3 x
is equal to 3 now
times 10
minus
3
squared
4 times 3 is 12 times 10 minus 3 is 7
squared so it's equal to 12 times 49 and
just to get the exact answer let's
multiply that so 49
times 12 2 times 9 is 18. 2 times 4 is 8
plus 1 is 9
0 one times nine is nine one times four
is four
and then we add the two
we get eight
nine plus nine is eighteen
and then one plus four is five hundred
and eighty eight